well I think the greatest challenge
first is having a solid idea that you
can build a business around I think it's
incredibly important that you you vet it
carefully and ask as many experts in the
field as you can for advice especially
if you're wrong person elderly people or
older people love to give you advice and
help you out so that would be the first
step I take to find out if you got a
good idea and if it's within your scope
of capability to make it happen there's
always plenty of capital around if you
have a good idea in structured well so I
think that that's where important
business planning comes in where you
show that you have a grasp of what it
will take to do it that you're not
overly ambitious you know the we see so
many business plans where it's kind of
stick with me you'll wear diamonds you
know kind of thing we want to know
there's reality underneath that we want
to know that you've really understood
how long it takes to put together a
sales organization or the develop a
product or to take from prototype to
packaged goods how difficult it is and
how challenging if you have a if you
convey that you have a sense of that I
think you have a a great chance to its
doing real well after you got that
kernel of an idea I think the next most
important thing you do is to kind of
structure it out carefully think about
the components of it begin to to talk to
the market and see our people really
interested you know a lot of us have
great ideas but the public's not
interested in so I think it's pretty
important to find out very very early on
if there is a market
you